- [Instructor] So we're
given this equation here.
And what I want you to
do is pause this video
and see if you can solve it.
What x values satisfy the equation?
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So one technique could be
just, let's just try to complete
the square here on the left-hand side.
So to do that, let me write it this way,
x squared minus eight x.
And then I have,
I'll write the plus one out here, is equal
to 85.
Now if I wanna complete the square,
I just have to think,
"What can I add to both
sides of this equation
"that could make this part
of the left-hand expression
"a perfect square?"
Well, if I look at this
negative eight coefficient
on the first-degree term, I could say,
"Okay, let me take half
of negative eight."
That would be negative four.
And then, negative four squared
is going to be positive 16.
So I'm gonna add positive
16 on the left-hand side.
And if I want, I could then subtract a 16
from the left-hand side.
Or I could add a 16 on
the right-hand side.
Notice, I've just done the same thing
to both sides of this equation.
And why was that useful?
Well, now what I've just put
in parentheses is a perfect square.
This is the same thing
as x minus four squared.
It was by design.
We looked at that negative eight.
Half of that is negative four.
You square it, you get 16.
And you can verify, x minus
four times x minus four is,
indeed, equal to this.
And then we have plus one is going
to be equal to, what's 85 plus 16?
That is 101.
And now we wanna get rid of this one
on the left-hand side.
And the easiest way we
can do that is subtract
one from both sides.
That way we'll just isolate
that x minus four squared.
And we are left with x minus four squared.
Four squared, these cancel out, is going
to be equal to 100.
Now if something squared is equal to 100,
that means that the something is equal
to the positive or the negative
square root of a hundred.
Or that that something,
x minus four, is equal
to positive or negative 10.
Positive or negative 10.
All I did is took the plus
or minus square root of a hundred.
And this makes sense.
If I took positive 10
squared, I'll get a hundred.
If I take negative 10
squared, I get a hundred.
So x minus four could
be either one of those.
And now I just add four to
both sides of the equation.
And then what do I get?
I get x is equal
to four plus or minus 10.
Or another way of thinking about it,
I could write it as x is equal
to, four plus 10 is 14.
And then four minus 10
is equal to negative six.
So these are two ways to solve it.
But there's other ways
to solve this equation.
We could, right from the get-go, try
to subtract 85 from both sides.
Some people feel more
comfortable solving quadratics
if they have that quadratic
expression be equal to zero.
And if you did that, you
would get x squared minus
eight x minus 84 is equal to zero.
All I did is I subtracted
85 from both sides
of this equation to get
this right over here.
Now this one we can approach
in two different ways.
We can complete the square again.
Or we could just try to factor.
If we complete the square,
we're going to see something
very similar to this.
Actually, let me just do that really fast.
If I look at this part, right over there,
I could say x squared minus eight x.
And then once again,
half of negative eight is negative four.
That squared is plus 16.
And then I'd have minus 84.
So let me do that in that blue color
so we can keep track.
Minus 84.
And then if I added 16
on the left-hand side,
I could either add that
to the right-hand side
so both sides have 16 added to it.
Or if I wanna maintain the equality,
I could just subtract 16
from the left-hand side.
So I've added 16, subtracted 16.
I haven't changed the
left-hand side's value.
And then that would be equal to zero.
This part right over here,
this is x minus four squared.
This part right over here is
minus 100 is equal to zero.
And then you add a hundred
to both sides of this
and you get exactly this
step right over here.
Now another way that we
could've approached it
without completing the square.
We could've said x squared minus
eight x minus 84 is equal to zero.
And think about what two numbers
if I multiply them I get negative 84.
So they'd have to have different signs,
since when I take their product
I get a negative number.
And when I add them together
I get negative eight.
And there we could just
look at the factorization
of negative 84, of 84 generally.
It could be two times,
let's just think about 84.
84 could be two times 42.
And obviously, one of them
would have to be negative,
one of them would have to be positive
in order to get to negative 84.
But the difference
between these two numbers,
if one was positive
and one was negative is
a lot more than eight.
So that doesn't work.
So let's try, let's see,
I'll do a few in my head.
Three times 28.
But still that difference
is way more than eight.
Four times, four times,
let's see, (mumbles).
Four times 21, no, that difference
between four and 21 is
still larger than eight.
Let's see, five doesn't go into it.
Six times 14, that's interesting now.
Okay, so let's think about this.
So six times 14 is equal to 84.
One of them has to be negative.
And since when we take the
sum of the two numbers,
we get a negative number,
that means the larger one is negative.
So let's see, six times
negative 14 is negative 84.
Six plus negative 14 is,
indeed, equal to negative eight.
So we can factor this as x plus six times
x minus 14 is equal to zero.
And so the product of those
two things is equal to zero.
That means if either of
them is equal to zero,
that would make the entire
expression equal to zero.
So we could say x plus
six is equal to zero.
Or x minus 14 is equal to zero.
Subtract six from both sides here.
We get x is equal to negative six.
Or add 14 to both sides here.
Or x is equal to 14.
Exactly what we got up here.